today your forces are moving forward
they face Fierce fighting but they are
gradually gaining ground
every meter
that Ukrainian forces regains
is a meter that Russia loses
stark contrast
ukrainians are fighting for their
families their future their freedom
Moscow is fighting for Imperial
delusions today I can confirm that NATO
now has framework contracts in place for
2.4 billion euros worth of key
ammunition including 1 billion euros or
firm orders
this covers capabilities like 155
millimeter artillery
anti-tank guided missiles and main
battle tank ammunition
this will help allies to refill their
stocks while continuing to support
Ukraine then regarding the
uh debris from uh drones in Romania
we don't have any indication that this
is a result of any intentional attack by
Russia against Allied territory but
Russia's
war and Reckless strikes close to the
Romanian borders are Reckless and are
destabilizing
foreign